a woman is now admitting that she was
paid to lie that dr. Anthony Fauci
sexually assaulted her this is the same
woman who lied that Robert Muller had
sexually assaulted her it appears that
exactly the same people put her up to it
now this story is crazy but I actually
think the context is what's most
disturbing and and outrageous and I'm
gonna explain that in a moment but first
the details woman named Diana Rodriguez
claimed that dr. Anthony foul tree the
country's lead infectious disease expert
he's been on Trump's White House
coronavirus task force he used to be a
fixture at the press briefings he
testified before the Senate yesterday
Diana Rodriguez claimed that foul she
sexually assaulted her in 2014 to a
reporter that reporter reasons Nancy
Rommel Minh had been working on the
story looking at the allegations from
Diana Rodriguez we've since learned that
Diana Rodriguez is really Diana Andrade
and she is actually connected to Jacob
wall a pro-trump troll who previously
tried to orchestrate completely bogus
sexual assault allegations against
Robert Muller during the time when
Robert Muller was doing the Trump Russia
investigations so once again you've got
the same people getting caught trying to
do the same thing trying to frame a
public figure that was inconvenient I
guess to the right with sexual assault
Diana Andrade said she was paid to come
forward with the bogus allegations so
those are the simple details but I
believe that the surrounding elements
are actually what's more important here
why is anybody trying to frame an
infectious disease doctor at all
why is Rand Paul as I will soon show you
going after dr. pouchy this is actually
the story a doctor who's simply doing
his job has done it four Republican
presidents and four Democratic
presidents is trying to save lives whose
ideology
he says his health and is nearly 80
years old I mean this guy's been doing
this for decade after decade this
diminutive 79 year old doctor has become
the enemy of the trumpet's right why is
he an enemy because he thinks he
says things which are based in science
and medicine which sometimes conflict
with the completely fake phony narrative
that Donald Trump concocts and creates
whether it's about fact-checking about
hydroxychloroquine whether it's about a
second wave whether it's about
vaccinations whether it's about
reopening whatever it is he has been
seen doctor foul G by the Trump astride
as an antagonist of Donald Trump when
really he is and I guess we would call
it an agonist for the truth and what
makes him invariably an enemy of the
trumpet's right is that he appears to
interfere with Donald Trump's lies
imagine doing your job so well being way
more trusted by the public than Trump by
the polls show conclusively the public
by large margins trusts Anthony Falchi
on an coronavirus way more than they
trust Donald Trump and the reaction from
some is this guy's the enemy fire foul
Chi and let's get somebody to lie and
claim doctor foul she sexually assaulted
them so Jacob wall and his partner
Berkman are of course a huge part of the
problem but the hostility among the
Trump is Right hostility to science
hostility to reason and to medicine and
to doctors and to Public Health that is
really the big story here now the second
part of this is why aren't jacob
wallenberg Minh in prison they tried to
frame robert muller and now they tried
to frame anthony foul gee is it because
the law doesn't matter anymore at
minimum in civil court you could see
lawsuits certainly over the robert
muller allegations and in reality it's
not outrageous to think that there could
be criminal charges here and once again
our country is an embarrassment truly
they're laughing at us all over the
world Germany Spain Italy France South
Korea Taiwan they take the virus
seriously they Revere their medical
experts they do what they're supposed to
do they deal with the virus and now they
can start to reopen to different degrees
in different countries depending on
what's going on meanwhile here in the
United States people demand that doctor
foul Chi be fired ignored and that
Donald Trump be listened to and now the
idea of frame
dr. Fuji with false sexual assault
allegations is uncovered um you know I
got emails yesterday about our story the
world is is laughing at Trump and it's
really bad for us and there were people
a lot of people from Europe and other
countries who said you know David we
were laughing we're not laughing anymore
now we just feel really bad for you guys
but we also are worried for ourselves
because we're used to the US as a
productive partner in solving problems
to the extent that we've been able to
solve problems in the past and the US
isn't that anymore so there's laughter
happening but there's also significant
concern that we are just so backwards on
every single one of these elements if
you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
linked Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic
to check it out on blinka blink east has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video